ils sont installés ici pour plusieurs
mois les équipes de dépollution sont à
pied d'oeuvre pour nettoyer le lieu de
l'incident plusieurs champs agricoles
ont été touchés par l'écoulement des 900
mètres cubes de pétrole derrière nous
nous avons des hydrocureurs qui sont en
train de pomper les arrivées
hydrocarbures qui sont collectés par les
drones et dans les piscines que nous
avons creusé dans des tranchées avec la
phase de nettoyage les équipes se penche
aussi sur le pipe line
après avoir extrait est mis sous scellés
pour l'anc est le morceau à l'origine de
la fuite
la réparation a commencé ainsi que la
dépollution des terres laissant la
hausse qui sont près de la fuite se sont
pollués c'est là bas qu'on va devoir
excavés c'est à dire retirer les terres
et les déposer à côté sur un liner et
les l'envoyer ensuite en dépollution et
comme le traitement va prendre du temps
nous on viendra et les terres de
substitution et c'est pour ça qu'il ya
déjà des discussions avec la chambre
d'agriculture avec ses agriculteurs pour
connaître quelles sont les
caractéristiques que vous avez dans ce
hall qu'on vous donne les mêmes terres
le chantier s'organisent en
collaboration avec les différentes
parties prenantes notamment les élus
locaux
nous avons pris un arrêté également de
l'interdiction de se servir des puits
pour l'instant c'est un arrêté près par
précaution une précaution prise aussi à
vic sur ce bassin à l'entrée du village
les hydrocarbures sont concentrées grâce
à la vanne guillotine pour faciliter le
travail de nettoyage et éviter
l'extension de la pollution facilité
depuis le champ par le système de
drainage le champ été drainés donc ce
sont des petits tuyaux qui sont dans le
sol qui sont ensuite renvoyés vers le
rue d'habitude ce sont des
de drains qui permettent aux dans
l'écouteur vous pas avoir trop d'eau
dans leurs champs la stratégie dans
laquelle on s'inscrit c'est vraiment
d'enlever les accumulation de colliers
en restant libre donc en surface que
l'on peut récupérer collecter aisément
pour libérer au maximum le milieu du pot
lyon et d'installer régulièrement des
points de contrôle la durée de
l'ensemble des travaux est estimé entre
6 et 8 mois
un calendrier qui pourraient être
affinée total s'engage à indemniser des
personnes impactées et à réhabiliter les
zones des chantiers